Our
computers rely on a power source to be
able to operate. But we also have to
consider our safety when it comes to
working inside of these computers. If
you're working on a computer, a printer,
or anything with a power cord, you
should always disconnect that power
source before working inside of those
devices. And if you are working inside
of those devices and you see a component
that you don't immediately recognize,
you should definitely not touch that
particular component. It's possible that
that device might have capacitors and
those capacitors may be storing power.
The power supplies that are inside of
these devices are designed to be
removable. So, you would remove the
entire power supply and replace it with
a brand new one. Generally, we don't
work on the inside of these power
supplies. And certainly there are
components inside of those power
supplies that could be harmful if you
were to touch them. Anytime you're
working with devices such as power
supplies, displays, or laser printers,
you should always keep in mind that
there may still be some residual power
inside of those devices. So, you should
always take proper precautions.
The goal of an electrical ground is to
take the power associated with an
electrical fault and put it onto that
ground connection instead of that power
going into you. This is an important
part of any electrical system. And
you'll notice that most of your
computing devices will have ground
connections on the power cord. If you're
in a data center, this also applies to
the racks that you have set up on the
data center floor. You not only want to
ground all of the components inside of
the rack, you also want to electrically
ground the rack itself. That way, if
there is power that finds its way onto
the metal rack, you can take all of that
power and send it to the ground. This is
why you should never remove any of those
ground connections from your power
plugs. And you should always make sure
that all of those racks are always
connected to an electrical ground. And
most importantly, you should never
connect any part of yourself to an
electrical ground. that electrical
ground could become energized and we
don't want any part of you to be
touching any other part of that
electrical ground.
We should not only be concerned about
power, but we should also be concerned
about the safety of our workspace. We
work with a lot of different cables and
we have to be very careful when we're
putting that cable somewhere near the
floor. This would create a trip hazard
for anyone walking by. So, you want to
be sure that you tape down or cover any
of these cables that may be in a walking
area. It might also be a good idea to
have all of these cables bundled
together to help prevent any type of
trip hazard. So, you should use Velcro,
cable ties, or anything else that can
group all of those cables together.
We also have to think about our own
personal safety. And there are things
you can do in the workplace to limit any
type of accident or injury. For example,
you should follow best practices for
lifting heavy equipment. We often deal
with printers and computers that are
relatively heavy. So, you want to be
sure that if you're lifting any of these
that you lift with your legs and you're
not lifting with your back. There's
specially designed equipment that you
can get for a data center that allows
you to slide this equipment into the
rack without having to lift and hold it
into the rack. Our electrical devices
also don't work very well with water.
You'll notice in a data center that we
don't use water and we don't use foam.
We instead use some other chemical such
as FM200, carbon dioxide, or some other
type of dry chemical. And of course, if
one of the devices you're working on
does catch fire, one of the things that
you want to do very quickly is remove it
from any power source.
Another good best practice is to always
wear safety goggles if you're working
with chemicals or anything else that
could splash on you. If you're working
inside of a printer with toner or you're
working with the chemicals that might be
associated with batteries, it's always a
good idea to have on a pair of safety
goggles. It's also very easy for dust or
toner to get into the air. So, if you're
working on a printer, you might want to
wear an air filter mask to prevent you
from breathing in any of that toner.
It's very possible that there are
existing health and safety laws that are
associated with working in some type of
technical environment. So, you might
want to check your local rules and
regulations to see what guidelines may
be in place for the job that you need to
do. When it comes to electrical safety
or fire prevention, there are usually
building codes that set minimum safety
standards for all of these environments.
And if you have a lot of old computers
and old batteries, there are usually
environmental regulations that cover how
and where you should dispose of all of
this equipment.